Lifelines can save you grief
just in case disaster strikes.
At the point where you want to insert
a lifeline, pull out all of the
needles just slightly, keeping the
stitches in the hooks of the needles.
Thread a darning needle or a double-eye
needle with a smooth contrasting
color thread or yarn, leaving the
stitches and the hooks of the needles.
Pull the strand through each stitch.
Continue running the strand
through each stitch across the row.
If the work dropped off the needles at
this point, the stitches would be secure.
Continue knitting according to
your pattern, ignoring the strand.
If disaster strikes, you can
confidently drop the work from the
machine and tear out to that lifeline.
Carefully pick up each stitch,
leaving the lifeline in place.
Then you can continue knitting.
Again, leaving the lifeline in place, just
in case when you've finished knitting the
piece, the lifeline will slip out easily.